salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
j'espère que vous avez passé un bon
réveillon et que vous n'avez pas trop la
gueule de
bois ça fait mal je vais parler
doucement avant toute chose je tenais à
vous souhaiter une bonne année à toutes
et à tous d'autant qu'elle va être
longue cette année vous êtes sûrement
déjà au courant elle va durer
366 jours et non 365 comme c'est le cas
habituellement une année bissextile
comme on dit alors ce n'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive cet
événement se produit tous les 4 ans
alors pourquoi ajouter un jour de plus
au calendrier tous les 4 ans enfin
presque tous les 4 ans on va éclaircir
tout
[Musique]
ça d'habitude le mois de février ne
compte que 28 jours mais cette année il
en comptera un de plus le 29 février
pour celles et ceux qui sont nés ce
jour-là c'est un peu pénalisant leur
anniversaire n'a lieu qu'une fois tous
les 4 ans c'est le cas par exemple de
l'acteur Gérard Armond il est né le 29
février
1948 à la date d'aujourd'hui il a donc
75 ans et pourtant il n'a fêté son
anniversaire que 18 fois alors pourquoi
ajoute-t-on un jour supplémentaire au
calendrier et bien c'est tout simplement
pour rattraper le temps perdu une année
vous le savez correspond au temps que
met la terre pour faire le tour complet
du soleil et revenir à sa position
initiale plus précisément le temps que
met la terre pour revenir à la position
qu'elle occupait au moment de l'équinoxe
du printemps dans les régions tempérées
là où notre calendrier a été mis au
point il est en effet très important de
déterminer avec précision le début et la
fin des saisons et de ne pas se décaler
cela permet de savoir quand il faut
semmer tailler ou récolter c'est sous
Jules César que le calendrier de 365
jours jour a été instauré avec des mois
comprenant 30 ou 31 jours à l'exception
du mois de février qui en compte 28
auparavant l'année faisait 355 jours et
on ajoutait un mois supplémentaire d'une
durée variable dans la foulée du mois de
février et c'est aussi Jules César qui a
instauré les années bissextiles en 46
avant Jésus-Christ vous le voyez ça ne
date pas d'hier mais pourquoi il a fait
ça parce qu'il s'est aperçu enfin lui et
astronomes que pour revenir à sa
position initiale la terre dans sa
course autour du Soleil ne mettait pas
365 jours mais un tout petit peu plus
365 jours et un quart de jour
supplémentaire et que si on n tenait pas
compte et bien on prendrait une journée
d'avance tous les 4 ans ainsi en 42
avant Jésus-Christ on fêterait le Nouvel
An le 30 décembre et non pas le 31
c'est-à-dire une journée avant que la
terre ne revienne à la place qu'elle
occupait un an plus tôt pour corriger le
tir on a donc ajouté une journée
supplémentaire au calendrier tous les 4
ans le fameux 29 février ces années-là
ont été qualifié de bissextile mais
pourquoi un 29 février et pourquoi une
année
bissextile il sort dou ce mot là parce
qu'à l'époque où les années étaient plus
courtes avant Jules César quand le
calendrier comptait moins de jours et
bien on ajouta une période dans la
foulée du mois de février par conséquent
quand il s'est agit d'ajouter un jour
supplémentaire c'est tout naturellement
vers le mois de février que les maîtres
du temps romain se sont tournés quant au
mot bissexyle il signifie 2 x 6e le jour
intercalaire à l'origine était placé
après le 24 février c'est-à-dire le 6e
jour avant les calendres de mars il
doublait ce jour
d'ù
bisextile maintenant comment savoir si
une année est bisextile justement c'est
simple elle doit être divisible par 4 et
le résultat doit être entier autrement
dit fournir un nombre rond comme on dit
sans virgule si vous préférez 2024 par
exemple divisé par 4 é= 506 nombre
entier c'est une année bissextile
1900/ 4 = 475 chiffreront 1900 oui et
bien non comment ça non les années
séculaires c'est-à-dire les années qui
finissent par de zé comme 1800 1900 ou
2000 doivent être divisible par 4 et par
400 et fournir un résultat rond or
1900/ 400 =
4,75 ce n'est donc pas une année
bissextile et 2100 ne le sera pas non
plus bah je comprends pas on dit tous
les 4 ans pourquoi supprimer des années
bissextiles l'histoire ne s'arrête pas
là c'est plus subtile sinon je n'aurais
pas fait une vidéo sur le sujet je
reprends Jules César et ses astronomes
avait fixé la durée de l'année à
365,25 jours en réalité la terre est un
peu moins de temps pour revenir à sa
position initiale
365,24 22 oh tu chipote ça fait 11
minutes 11 minutes et 14 secondes
précisément d'une année sur l'autre
c'est peu mais à la longue ça fait
beaucoup ça représente une journée tous
les 128 ans ce qui a fini par poser un
problème avec le calendrier religieux
certaines fêtes ayant lieu à date fixe
comme Noël le 25 décembre mais d'autres
étant fluctuante car fixé par rapport au
calendrier lunaire pâqu par exemple à ce
rythme on fêterait donc les cloches
avant Noël impensable vous imaginez bien
c'est pour cette raison qu'en 1582 le
pape Grégoire X3 a décidé de retirer
certaines années bissextiles on l'a vu
dans la mesure où l'écart s'élève à un
jour d'avance tous les 128 ans cela fait
2 jours tous les 256 ans 3 jours tous
les 384 ans il a donc été décidé de
supprimer 3 jours tous les 400 ans pas
d'un seul coup évidemment en fait il a
été décidé que 1700 1800 1900 qui
comptait 366 jours dans le calendrier
julien le calendrier de Jules César ne
serait plus bissextile 2000 en revanche
le resterait bref à partir de 1582 ne
sont bissextiles que les années divisi
par 4 et les années centenaires
divisibles par 4 et 400 avec un résultat
entier drôle d'année
1582 pour remettre les pendules à l'URE
enfin faire coïncider le calendrier
civil ou plutôt religieux à l'époque
avec le calendrier solaire on a retiré
certaines années bissextiles mais ce
n'est pas la seule transformation qu'
qu'on a fait subir au calendrier cette
année-là tu as raison en 1582 on est
passé directement du 4 au 15 octobre
c'est dingue ça vous lirez aussi parfois
que cette anomalie s'est produite en
décembre tout simplement parce que cette
correction ne s'est pas faite partout au
même
moment en fait cette année-là le pape
Grégoire X3 et ses équipes ont fait les
comptes ils se sont aperçus que depuis
la décision de Jules César d'instaurer
une année sextile systématiquement tous
les 4 ans autrement dit depuis que la
durée de l'année était estimée à
365,25 jours et non
365,2422 que depuis tout ce temps on
avait accumulé un retard de 10 jours
pour remettre les pendul à l'heure il
fut tout simplement décidé de supprimer
10 jours au calendrier en 1582 on est
passé directement du 4 au 15 octobre
selon c'est un peu plus de 2000 bébés
voient le jour chaque 29 février en
France ni plus ni moins que les autres
jours ce qui est beaucoup plus rare
c'est qu'une femme donne naissance à
plusieurs enfants un 29 février je ne
parle pas de jumeaux hein non des
enfants qui naissent 2 29 février
consécutif cela s'est produit à Nant il
y a quelques années une maman a accouché
d'un petit garçon le 29 février 2012 et
4 ans plus tard le 29 février 2016 elle
a don naissance à une petite fille dans
l'UTA aux États-Unis une femme a
accouché de trois enfants un 29 février
en 2004 2008 et 2012 la plupart des
personnes nées ce jour-là c'est le cas
de Gérard Armond on en a parlé un peu
plus haut choisissent en général de
fêter leur anniversaire la veille le 28
février pour leur éviter ce désagrément
l'île de Taïwan a carrément décidé de
supprimer le 29 février comme date de
naissance les bébés qui viennent au
monde ce jour-là sont enregistré au 28
voilà c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui bon
je sais commencé l'année avec des
chiffres c'est un peu compliqué mais
comme on dit les bons compes font les
bons amis et ça c'est une belle promesse
pour 2024 encore une fois très bonne
année et à très bientôt chers épicurius
et épicurieux
ép
cuux